2d ok so now i'm going to substitute
this in noting I've got a log this is
needed by the way and another log I can
put this together into a single line
right so I'm going to say T equals I'll
do the substitution first and then I'll
combine my logs this one's positive this
one's negative so if i take out a factor
of 40 what's going to be on the inside
of my lord what do you very good
wonderful so this one really should be
first and i divide through by this guy
yep awesome I have a time expression
okay time function so this is really
easy to draw all right i think IM cost
okay now hold on this is not that hard
to rearrange right because look at it
look this is going to be an exponential
right it's going to be a stupid job so
if I well if I should put this some 40
over here I'm guessing
negative our wouldn't that be easier
yeah so in fact I'm going to put the
negative in because why am I putting a
negative in what I want is that V to be
up on the numerator here now it's kind
of an awkward spot at the moment so if i
multiply both sides by negative 1 that's
going to become this over here and over
here these males of you because it's to
the power of negative one so far so good
yep i'm going to laze both sides of the
power of e to power off that like this
what happens to the right-hand side it's
just that right I'm going to simplify
that in one here that's for TG minus
sorry 40 hero EG minus me or for you do
yeah that these guys are going to switch
so i'm gonna get this guy over here this
guy over here and then i'm going to
divide multiply clear glass ok now just
pause for a moment you've gone through
all of this calculus does it natural to
expect to happen when you draw this
graph we're going to do these at the
same time me and go through what the
picture looks like when time is equal to
0 I already know what the velocity is ok
so what happens to the time the velocity
rather as time gets bigger and bigger
and bigger what happens to this whole
term over here
it sort of disappears away and all you
get left with is this guy okay so you're
approaching a limit we know what that's
going to be right so that'll be our
answer for Part C let's do what seems
pretty simple yes you could that's
another way to do there's this both ways
to do it with weapon so I'm getting this
asymptote up here and it's going to be
like this happy this is a time axis and
a normal sir so now is Part B what's
very complicated now when you're
answering party there's two ways to go
about this okay two ways you can think
about it from a limit point of view
because that's what the term velocity is
after all or you can think about it from
our Newton's laws point of view okay so
we'll do them each one at a time so
number one if you were to do this by
limits you don't need to do both of
these by just showing you each one the
terminal velocity is what's the volsung
terminating on as time approaches
infinity right so I'm literally interact
on limit as T approaches infinity of
velocity right now have a velocity
function just over there so this is the
limit as T approaches infinity 0 for TG
1 minus lights up okay for TG is a
constant so I'm going to bring that guy
out of the front the limit is still
there you can take that back i can
evaluate the limit this is going to be
one takeaway it's not open everything
it's just going to become zero right I
like whatever into parent so 1 times for
TG this is my terminal for setting I'm
just getting it from the
definition at 12 over 2 years but
secondly remember what we said about
terminal velocity and his laws this is
uniform straight line worship which
means what about the acceleration to
infiltrate there's no acceleration
acting on the body right now go back go
back where is acceleration written down
in the cleaner simplest form before we
started mucking with it so we could get
okay it is pretty simple there but I've
got a statement in here an equation that
literally says acceleration is this
genealogy one for that one right do you
see that there and that we wrote this
which shows that so I could get to my
philosophy so I'm just going to go back
to you and say number two by on the
first of all if there's tone of velocity
terminal velocity means or indicates
zero acceleration
so I'm going to go over to my
acceleration function and I'm just going
to say that G minus 1 on for TV that
better be 0 because otherwise it's not
terminal velocity is it something still
changing its velocity so this as you can
see it's very simple to solve I'll leave
this guy on this side negative G and
then you multiply through to get them
that we already knew okay so i know this
is fun yeah alright lastly i'm just
going to leave this with you to do on
your own because we're running out of
time how we going to get to this it's
very similar to a very nice okay so
you've got your font your velocity
function and all used to do is say well
that's the XL UT and this is already in
terms of time so off you go integrate
again and you're done